sí
[Música]
listo
nuestra colina
y los dos estar conectando con los tres
para compartirles que tener métodos
maravilloso para reaccionar galletas
para durar más tiempo
sabemos que estamos viviendo así es más
difícil porque no será fácil salir a
comprar antes de cuarentena y pasar
momentos en que yo debe cuarto al
cachetazo pero difícil lograrlo todo
una vez tú quieres regalar galletas a
lola para su cumpleaños pero cada
charola con galletas recién horneadas
que salir
8 nunca iba a lograr juntar está quieta
para arreglarlo
entonces carolina ayudarme a lograr
controlar impulso de comer todo estás
blasco chips y lograrlo
en efecto come galletas aplicó algunas
estrategias para lograr su meta de
juntar suficientes galletas para su
amiga lola esas estrategias forman parte
de lo que conocemos como la
autorregulación y nos ayudan a controlar
nuestros impulsos enfocar nuestra
atención manejar nuestras emociones y
muchas cosas más de las que imaginamos
pero abren 40 volverse muy muy difícil
lograrlo
empezar a sentir extraño por no poder
comer coche estás como antes
porque acabarse y no poder salir a
comprar más ingredientes para cocinar o
empezar a desesperar
yo no sabe cómo es ese ticket o no debe
comer o no poder hornear o sigue sutil o
mientras suena que te sientes lo está
creo que por estos días muchas personas
y muchos monstruos se sienten frustrados
junto otros incluso nos sentimos
enojados tristes aburridos ansiosos de
tal mal sentir todas estas cosas todos
nos sentimos así yo sentir frustrado y
hay algo triste y yo querer comer
galletas como antes como siempre
galletas galletas
es importante que puedas decir lo que
siempre es poder hablar sobre nuestras
emociones y sentimientos es el primer
paso para poder manejarlas positivamente
ser verdad ahora yo poder decir que yo
sentir miedo por qué
solo queda una patineta
una una leche de chispas de chocolate o
semi favorita
yo quería comer vamos pero no poder
comer porque si yo comer entonces sólo
quedar se eroga cierta o yo no poder
tener 0 galletas no no no no no no no
pero pero es que está estar tan
recuerdas la estrategia hemos estado
practicando para estos momentos porque
no nos muestras a los demás cómo hacerlo
yo sabe
y olvidar tu ayuda está bien vamos a
hacerlo juntos primero vamos a parar
y vamos a respirar
si yo recordar cómo hacerlo con windows
mobile jaja sí y no hablar con youtube
y exhalar negatividad y de hablar
gratuita
exelon digo tipitos y nos largos
y exhalar de cautividad y yo sentirme
muy bien y muy tranquilo efectivamente
cuando respiramos nos conectamos con lo
que está pasando en nuestro cuerpo y
podemos ver con más claridad lo que
podemos hacer y ahora estar más calmado
necesitar pensar un plan para guardar
última caseta
vamos a pensar qué puedes hacer para
alcanzar tu mente y yo recortador si
cuando tienes que esperar poder hablar
con mis compis y mo pasó muy bien una de
las mejores estrategias que podemos
utilizar cuando tenemos un desafío es
hablar con nosotros mismos de manera
cómoda para hablar conmigo yo te sigo
con mi coche estás
tu poder guardar último cachito tuvo a
ser mejores pues y lograr lo que querer
y yo ahora sentir más tranquilo y saber
que tú lograrlo
ja ja ja ja ja
también recordar otras técnicas que
contarme cuando sentir ansioso que
aplicar el sol
dt es una excelente técnica vamos a
mostrarle a todos comenzando
plantas en firmemente en el piso como si
fueran una palmera con raíces profundas
profundas y una rama largas largas
empiecen primero a sacudirse lentamente
de un lado a lucy y cada vez más rápido
más rápido más rápido más rápido más
rápido va rápido y cuando estos bichos
también no preocuparse su grupo con
variado jajaja
sí y eso también servirme para controlar
todas las de comer última galleta
y ahora estar convencido de poder comer
la mañana
oyó sentir orgulloso de mí y yo estaré
muy contento conmigo por lograr guardar
la dieta
así sentirse lucrar verdad
me alegra mucho que te sientas orgulloso
has perseverado he hecho un gran
esfuerzo y en cierto grado tu objetivo
dominar estas técnicas requiere práctica
y paciencia pero como todo lo que
aprendemos se vuelve más fácil cuanto
más lo hagamos
ustedes también pueden fomentar las
habilidades de autorregulación en casa
haciendo uso de las estrategias que nos
ha mostrado con este paso
controlar ser muy importante y sentir
orgulloso cuando lograrlo
la persistencia para lograr la
autorregulación es fundamental no comer
una galleta puede parecer algo fácil
pero
fácil fácil
no no no no con el coche está nunca ser
fácil no no no eso haber quedado
demostrado quiero decir que todos
tenemos esa galleta que no nos podemos
comer o ese obstáculo que parece
demasiado grande para superarlo pero
estas técnicas realmente ayudan para los
niños y las niñas más pequeñas la
galleta puede ser esperar su turno para
jugar o esperar a que sus padres se
desocupen cuando están en una
videollamada en casa o ser pretelt
secreto yo conociera amigo que es el muy
difícil de dejar de contar y hecho estar
todo el tiempo
colo colo colo
tal vez cuando ella pérez tu hecho
aprender a controlar y no cantar cuando
no sirvo un vento claro seguro tú serás
un gran ejemplo para ella así como los
niños aprenden de los adultos cómo
manejar situaciones desafiantes seguro
tu amiga aprenderá difíciles compartes
de estas técnicas así no sólo alcanzarán
su objetivo sino que adquirirán
destrezas que les ayudarán toda la vida
y algunas recompensas que también llegan
de sorpresa
exacto la sorpresa hacer
sorpresa 4 expresa de qué sorpresa
hablar la repubblica
no puedo decirlo porque dejaría de hacer
sorpresa
carolina
carolina carolina no ser el momento de
celular extra el momento de hablar de
cómo guardar tarjetas de cómo controlar
dejar celular ya tu controlar lo siento
tenía que ver cuánto sorpresa
es que cuando el vuelo lo supieron que
no tenías más galletas en casa y que no
podía salir a comprar más se pusieron de
acuerdo conmigo para enviar los
ingredientes a tu casa y así pueden
hacer los galletas juntos
o sí pero como cuando donde los
ingredientes están llegando a tu casa en
ese momento pero vas a tener que esperar
un par de días para tener la
videollamada con el vuelo lan
un porte dios
si tendrás que esperar
eso no está el problema yo poder
controlar jajaja
sí sí sí
yo debe despedir y recibir ingredientes
que enviarán amigos pero antes de decir
hasta pronto recordar no llorar porque
caché está acá para sonreír porque calle
te existe ja ja ja ja
hasta pronto este proyecto
las dos regulaciones un conjunto de
habilidades que utilizamos cada día pero
los primeros años de vida son el momento
más crítico para empezar a
desarrollarlas en un momento desafiante
como este inviertan tiempo y esfuerzo en
practicar estas habilidades con los
niños y las niñas así no sólo harán más
llevadera esta etapa sino que les
dejarán un legado que los acompañará
toda la vida